jenny vance is running against tim ryan
for u.s senate seat this november he
joins us tonight jd vance thanks so much
for coming on this seems like a
completely crazed and fringe position is
it in ohio
i definitely think it is tucker and you
hit the nail on the head here this is
terrible for ohio consumers i mean
people should be able to drive whatever
car they want to because this is america
and people have the freedom to choose
but it's also if you think about this as
a massive class war against ohio auto
workers
why should we all be denied gas-powered
cars why should ohio auto workers be put
out of a job because tim ryan's donors
who own the electric car companies
want to get a little richer
that's not representing the people of
ohio it's sure as hell not representing
the interests of the middle class in
ohio and of course that's not what tim
ryan's interested in he's interested in
representing his donors so they can
continue to fund his fraudulent campaign
why is it always banning this that or
the other thing i'm banning you know
cigarettes anything that you enjoy
they're banning why don't you say i'm
going to make a car that's so great
you're going to want to buy it isn't
that kind of the american way why does
tim ryan go right to making it illegal
well it goes right to making it illegal
because he knows that his preferred
green energy fantasy that he'd like to
project onto the entire state of ohio
won't happen through free choice he
recognizes that unless the government
forces this on people nobody's going to
go for it and i have to say tucker i
mean this is why people need to support
my campaign jdvance.com because what
he's doing is fundamentally trying to
transform the country and it's going to
make a lot of us poorer if if we let him
do it we can't let him do that
and he's pretending to be some kind of
working man voice to the people i mean
it's just so insulting if you listen to
what he actually says jenny vance great
to see you tonight thank you
thanks tucker
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight